okay so we we finally have
an answer for what is fat activism and
this answer i
like very much we're going to share it
uh with the audience anyway so what
fat activism is for me um i've been
thinking and
about and working on the question what
is for activism
daily not very much for the past of 25
years or so you know
i still don't have an easy answer um and
it's a question that i came to in my
master's dissertation
which was published as my book fat and
proud in 1998 which was ages ago now
and i returned to it for my phd which
was a four-year research project that i
finished last november
and during that project i interviewed
about 30 fat activists around the world
people of all different backgrounds and
perspectives many of whom
had decades of experience in fat
activism
and nobody gave me a consistent answer
about what it actually is
because they were chewing so given this
it made sense to me that fat activism
can be absolutely anything it just
really depends on the context i like
that and this makes fat activism really
exciting because
it means you can tailor it you can tell
it to what you're interested in yes
or the things that you enjoy or the
things that you're good at or your very
very specific moments in your life yes
and so i kind of thought that so if i'm
just being fat
and rude and nasty in the lobby of a
hotel
because i've come down a few minutes
after the
the breakfast has ended and i'm really
giving it
to the people that work there and i'm
giving it to them good is that
this sounds like that is fat activism
well i like that if i throw a fit
an enterprise rent a car because the car
they gave me is what i consider to be
uh too small that is fat activism
i'm now coming around to this and
enjoying it
let's let's watch a little more
something really big like a street
protest that's the thing that most
people
think of as activism when i talk to
people about it or a letter writing
campaign that kind of thing
and it can be as small as a wink a wink
directed at the right person at the
right time yes
well that's that i that i like
what she's basically saying is we don't
need these street protests
where everybody has to walk and chaff
but a wink a well-placed
wink is fat activism
wink i will wink and make people
uncomfortable and i think that's a good
barrier of entry it's low so the idea is
that
a well-placed wink to the right person
is fat activism let's say
okay if i and i've actually done this
right i've been in 7-eleven
and i was eating the big on the big on
is a cheeseburger that you heat in the
microwave
and you take it out of his wrapper and
i've been
with the big on in 7-eleven eating it
you know putting the pickles for the
condiment bar on the on
and squeezing ketchup on it and biting
it and if i
choose to wink at the cashier
i'm engaging in the important work of
fat activism
let's see what else this is really
this is uh beautiful
and it can involve changing laws but it
can also involve having a conversation
with somebody
or wearing something good and sometimes
it's about
refusal of dominant cultural values and
sometimes it's really really
ambiguous some fat activists try and
draw lines about what
is and what isn't for activism but i
think that kind of ideological purity is
completely overrated
and i'm interested in those kind of
hybrids um that people develop for
themselves and kind of
try and draw in to make livable lives
um my fat activism is a part of my daily
life i don't put on a
uniform or an outfit or something
special to do it
right we'll go somewhere me too it's
really embedded in the way that i think
about things
the work that i do the people i know yes
it's there in how i walk and how i talk
yes and i don't see much separation
between activism
and life right um you can think of it as
a kind of consciousness
yes um sometimes i do stuff that's more
recognizable as
activism i make things make sense which
are
small homemade publications okay like
this one
which i have for free you can have a
copy afterwards if you want
and sometimes i write and publish things
like my book and i've
published stuff in well i'm on sitting
on the board for the
the fat studies journal it's an
interdisciplinary journal of body weight
and society there's a mouthful for you
how do you get in there contribute to
books like the fat the fat studies
reader
and also our own beautiful fat studies
in the uk which karina
co-edited so i do stuff that is activism
and sometimes my activism is very small
and subtle
can be something like breathing or
thinking
or um
hold on
this woman just said her fat activism
was the act of breathing
that she could just be somewhere
breathing and she's being an activist
isn't that isn't that sort of proving
that being fat isn't healthy
if breathing is activism
aren't you giving away the game there a
bit
if you look my fat activism sometimes is
very simple
it's not breathing or getting out of a
chair
doesn't that suggest
that being overweight is potentially
unhealthy i'm no doctor neither is
rhonda patrick
but i still think that there's something
about
breathing as activism that denotes
probably not the healthiest lifestyle
but again what do i know but all right
let's we we've had enough thank you we
get we kind of get it now
it's everything it's nothing it's
breathing
it's winking at people
whatever you want to do plus size models
send death threats by
fat activists after dieting this is what
i like
now this is what i like i like this
i like a fat person threatening to kill
a another fat person who's started to
get thinner
that to me is an interesting type of
person and one that i want to know more
about
the person that rosie mercado who used
to be a size 24 and is now a size 12 to
14. still fat
right good was told to jump off a bridge
and kill herself by people
with people who objected their slimming
down the 36 year old told tmz i got hate
mail
not so much from other models just fans
that hated on me
wow they hated the thought that i was
really public about my weight loss and i
was losing weight she lost more than 170
pounds
some people love being overweight some
people don't that's what she says
i think it's a personal choice but
people were not happy
they were sending her threatening
they were threatening they would tell
her to kill herself oh she was 410
pounds too she was 410 pounds and then
she got
and she lost 170 pounds well she's down
to 170 now yeah no
go up oh wow
she's 170. wow good for her she went
from four no
no no no
no good for her no
you skinny piece of [ __ ]
she's a benedict arnold
there is a movement of fat activists
that do activism by breathing heavily
yes but
she's i can't believe you would say that
and be so heartless
the people that loved her as a 410 pound
model want her to kill herself
and jump off a bridge because she's now
down to 170.
the only reason i'm not afraid of that
is people are telling me to kill myself
anyway they're saying it now